Student Sanjayman asks what are the major problems search engines are trying to solve today.
So I hope we’ll see some creative solutions of new things that you can do
with search engines as part of the contest
and we will be releasing the full details on that soon.
The kinds of things that are probably the biggest things
that commercial search engines are working on today,
one is always getting better results, right.
Finding better ways to find the best page,
finding ways to respond queries that are more complex
and have more than just one keyword, doing things
that will get people what they are searching for.
The other thing that I think is probably a big effort
and is an increasing arms race is dealing with efforts
to get pages ranked highly that aren’t active,
so people are trying to do things, they call it link spam sometimes
trying to make pages that will rank highly but don’t have good content
and this is sort of a never ending battle between the search engine companies
and the people who want to create content that ranks highly.
Every time Google tweaks their algorithm, lots of people get upset
because their PageRanks go down. That could be unfair.
It could be because they have good content and that new algorithm is unfair to them.
It could be because the algorithm has been tweaked to try to remove things
from high ranks that don’t have the content that users are actually looking for.
So that’s really a never ending battle to try to get the best results.
And there is also a lot of effort to kind of instead of just
returning a query - returning results for a given search query but to answer questions.
Yeah.
And so you can go into whatever search engine you use and ask like,
when is new year, what day is new year or the Chinese new year
and it’ll give you the date instead of just – in addition to the results
and will start answering questions and this is kind of the first step
into kind of organizing search engines around what we want to know.
And in some search engines like Google and DuckDuckGo
are pretty good with questions like that.
To actually understand natural language well enough to be able to answer
a complex question that doesn’t fit some known structure
is a really hard problem but is definitely something that is
in the future of search engines to do that well.